this Tommy who's the dad and being good
does that make you kind of fall back in
love with him I've never been out of
love with Tommy what happened why it
seems to me like maybe that should have
been the perfect union it probably
should have we probably should have
stuck it out I don't know I hope he you
know but again at the time you know it
was those craziness going on we had all
those people following us around we were
married young married quick we had
babies right away and and then you know
and then I think he was like the whole
point the whole when he went to jail and
everything like that was he was taking
steroids I thought he was on heroin I
was finding these needles you know it
was like he was trying to get big and
for me for me was kind of sad but you
know we still didn't handle ourselves
right and and it fell apart and we tried
back and forth back and forth and and I
don't think it's a good living
relationship when you're around him and
and the kids bring back all the good
times you know like hey you know we were
really in love we actually had children
together and the kids know that they
were born out of true love like real
love so they they know that